Montagnachmittag in Leipzig auf dem
Augustusplatz Aufbau für die
auftakt-demos zum sogenannten heißen
Herbst die Linkspartei vor der Oper und
nur 100 Meter weiter die sogenannten
freien Sachsen vor dem Gewandhaus was
treibt die Menschen her
ich habe nun auch zwei Systeme
mitgemacht ich habe einen 89 erlebt das
ging mit wenigen Menschen los und auf
einmal waren 100.000 auf der Straße ne
und auf einmal brauchen alles zusammen
und davor habe ich einfach Angst
überhaupt nicht einbüßen warum ich habe
Angst von dem wie das weitergeht und ich
suche von von allen Seiten ich war schon
vergangenen Montag da waren ziemlich
radikale Parteien hier drüben und heute
werde ich mir das war die freien Sachsen
an jetzt stecken wir dort massiv Waffen
in dieses Kriegsgebiet in dieses
Krisengebiet und denken wir machen damit
Frieden und anderen auch dieser Punkt
belastet mich und führt mich hierher ein
weiterer Punkt ist der damit verbundene
soziale Abstieg von Millionen von
Menschen in diesem Land wo jetzt die
Konzerne massiv Profite machen und
dieses Gefühl was wir jetzt machen
müssen um uns zu wehren weil unsere
Mittelstand geopfert wird dieses Gefühl
ist für Frau ihre Mutter für
Selbstständige
Mittelstandsbetriebe ganz ganz schlimm
wir haben Existenzängste wir werden
gemolken wie eine Kuh und wie ist das
mit einer Kuh die immer mehr Milch geben
muss die wird jeden Tag mehr gemolken
aber das können wir uns nicht gefallen
lassen und deswegen sind wir jetzt hier
die Kleinstpartei von Martin Kohlmann
gilt als rechtsradikal und deshalb für
den Verfassungsschutz als Verdachtsfall
die freien Sachsen hatten im Internet
für eine gemeinsame Demo mit den Linken
geworben am Montag wollte der
Vorsitzende aber plötzlich davon nichts
mehr wissen wir würden auch ehrlich
gesagt uns schwer tun Gregor Gysi auf
unsere Demo reden zu lassen also wir
haben schon ein bisschen Verantwortung
für das was bei uns auch gesagt wird und
da würde jetzt ja Gisi nicht so richtig
reinpassen also das war nicht so gemeint
und sollte auch nicht so verstanden
werden ihr Plakat war getrennt
marschieren gemeinsam Schlager das ist
für mich unmissverständlich was meinen
Sie mit gemeinsamen missverständlich
sehe ich auch so und gemeinsam schlagen
heißt hoffentlich gemeinsam was
erreichen nämlich eine Änderung dieser
darfst du nicht ein Politik gemeinsam
schlagen
100 Meter weiter vor der Oper der
provokative fake-aufruf der freien
Sachsen hatte im linken Lager für
heftige Debatten gesorgt genau wie die
Wahl des bedeutungsschweren montags als
Demo Termin
wir haben angeknüpft an die Erfahrungen
auch von denen die 2004 schon auf diesem
Platz damals gegen die sozialen
Verwerfungen gegen die Hartz-IV-Gesetze
demonstriert hat und wir hatten gesagt
als Auftakt sollte es in Leipzig der
Montag sein wir laden alle ein die einen
friedlichen Staaten sozialen Protest auf
die Straße bringen wollen und wir machen
das in breiten Bündnissen auch heute
hier werden Vertreterinnen und Vertreter
verschiedener Initiativen von sozialen
Bewegungen aber auch bei unserer Partei
miteinander reden ich finde wer sich
politisch umschaut in Sachsen aber auch
in Ostdeutschland der muss zur Kenntnis
nehmen dass wir schon eine rechte
Dominanz auf den Straßen haben und das
nicht seit gestern ich finde es gibt
sieben Tage die Woche und man kann sich
die sechs Tage die nicht der Montag sind
aussuchen zum Protestieren und dann
braucht dieses Kräftemessen nicht das
war wichtig dass wir uns die
Demonstration nicht nehmen lassen wenn
wir jetzt wirklich die Kundgebung
abgesagt hätten und in Demonstration bei
die Rechten gleichzeitig irgendwas
machen dann hätten wir tatsächlich die
soziale Frage auf die Rechten übertragen
das überhaupt nicht zu die beiden
Versammlungen blieben getrennt Störungen
gab es kaum aus linker Sicht ein
wichtiger und erfolgreicher Abend
deswegen bin ich stimme zu zeigen die
Linke Stimme legen die Idioten von
rechts und das nochmal die Linke wieder
präsent ist
extrem inkorrekt finde wie mit dem
Menschen hier umgegangen wird allgemein
es werden 100 Milliarden für den Krieg
gelockert aber gleichzeitig kommen Geld
für soziale Projekte frei gemacht es
wird immer gesagt wir sitzen alle im
gleichen Boot aber das stimmt einfach
nicht wir sitzen nicht im gleichen Boot
und zwar was hier gerade passiert ist ja
eine Umverteilung von unten nach oben
das heißt Leute verdienen gerade an der
Krise an der corona-pandemie schon aber
jetzt noch mal
und diejenigen die dafür zahlen das sind
wir die am Ende ich bin zum Beispiel der
Solo selbstständige ich fand es auch
sehr gut das ist sehr viele aussah
parlamentarische politische Initiativen
aus dem blickgespektrum gab die das
heute mit unterstützt haben weil die
Linke ist nicht unbedingt
ist nicht selbstverständlich dass wenn
die Linkspartei irgendwohin mobilisiert
dass dann auch Gruppen aus dem aus der
parlamentarischen Spektrum mit dabei
sind deswegen fand ich das war heute ein
sehr gelungener Schulterschluss jeder
Mensch darf in diesem Land demonstrieren
aber wir waren mehr wir waren lauter und
wir haben deutlich gemacht dass wir mit
Rassisten und Nationalisten keiner
gemeinsame Sache machen wollen oder
werden die können sich Ihre Querfront
gerne herbeifantasieren aber da werden
wir nicht mitmachen und
trotz allem weiter unseren sozialen
Protest auf die Straße tragen abgesehen
von kleineren Zusammenstößen im Nachgang
der Demos blieb ist friedlich es war ein
ruhiger Auftakt für den kommenden
unruhigen Herbst